We are the New York Knicks.
We are the [inaudible].
Joining me today is the New York Times bestselling author,
the guy who wrote that mid nineties New York Knicks anthem,
a man who has founded enterprises from private jet companies to Zico coconut
water,
the Co owner of the Mbas,
Atlanta Hawks and Oh,
a former rapper Jesse.
It's lyrical.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Uh,
thanks for having me,
dude.
Your bio is like,
like it doesn't even seem like it could possibly be real.
It's been quite a journey.
Quite a journey.
All right.
There's so much I want to do with you.
I,
I said to you right before we started,
I mean I remember that 94 Nick's team so well that was like right in my
formative years of basketball,
which I love.
I said to you right before we started that that game six,
which as a Knicks fan is probably one of the most painful things you ever
watched.
A was the night of my senior prom and of course tonight of the Oj Simpson car
chase,
you lived through that whole experience.
I did.
I was at the Knick game that night.
I was at the Knick game as a playoff game.
I had just written the theme song for the Knicks and started,
it was starting to get momentum on the radio and in the garden and I was so,
I mean my whole life up a knick fan and this was a big moment and here we are,
game six at home and all of a sudden the Oj Chase,
I was getting like a pretzel.
I went outside,
I was like,
everyone's looking at the monitor and I looked up,
I'm like,
what in the world is this?
Oh Wow.
So they were showing you like don't go out to the concessions.
Yeah,
it was on the Monitor.
So you know I was conflicted and people were running back and forth.
It was wild.
Yeah.
What a crazy night because the rangers had just won the Stanley Cup finals I
think.
And it was just like a great time to be in New York.
Then Oj,
obviously people must've been talking about my prom,
so I can only imagine what was going on over there.
All right,
so speaking of New York,
you're from Roslyn Long Island.
I'm from Syosset Long Island.
We're about 10 minutes away from each other on the long island expressway.
I find that a lot of interesting people come out of long island had,
have you found that?
Is that the water?
What's going on?
You know,
it's crazy.
I was telling,
I was actually just having this conversation the other day with a friend of mine
and I was saying in my town,
if you took the year that I graduated my senior year and went back four years
and forward four years,
so in that eight year gap or whatever it is from,
you know,
of kids that went through my school.
We have a,
I think we have two with three professional sports team owners.
We have multiple billionaires.
I have five guys that I went to high school is that are in jail.
We've had multiple suicides and Bernie Madoff was from my town.
I look at my town and think that everybody had the same opportunity.
Same teachers.
We had one movie theater.
I mean it was a small,
relatively small town.
One,
one real high,
one high school that everyone went to.
A real sense of community,
everyone at the same basically,
you know,
journey through as far as teachers and everything.
Yet we had this crazy swing of the biggest Ponzi schemer and his,
his family and sons where in our school,
you know,
guys who were super successful,
people that had super successful parents that went to jail.
I mean all in this community.
And it was like,
Whoa,
what was in the water?
Yeah.
In this town.
What do you make of that actually?
Cause there's gotta be something there.
I mean,
even my high school,
I mean there,
I knew a couple people that I went to high school with that ended up in jail,
but we also had Judd Apatow into my high school.
Idina Menzel huge Broadway star.
Natalie Portman.
Yeah.
I went to my high school and,
and all sorts of things.
I think that I would feel very lucky that I grew up in a town that I grew up in
and the area that we grew up in.
Yeah.
That,
um,
you know,
it was,
it was diverse.
There was a lot of opportunity.
There was creativity.
It wasn't far from the city.
So we had like a little bit of the city vibe.
Is that what it is?
I think it has something to do with the proximity because we were about 45
minutes away from New York City.
Most of our parents,
I'm guessing maybe your parents who worked in New York City,
so there was like a little bit of a commuter thing,
but you weren't totally part of New York.
Like something related to that.
I think that's part of it.
I think for me,
I think it's just the time period that I grew up,
you know,
as a kid.
Yeah.
Uh,
and there was just a change in music change in culture and uh,
we would just expose being close to the city.
We had early exposure to all those trends and we were early to the party and I
think that had a big impact.
At least it did for me.
I know he's an entrepreneur and in my journey it was exciting.
There was always excitement.
I want to be a part of everything.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
I got addicted to newness because there was always something new going on and
uh,
that fueled me even going forward.
So I feel very lucky that,
you know,
we grew up where we did.
Yeah.
Anything else I should know about your,
your formative years are family before we get into some of the things that you,
uh,
no,
no.
You can ask me.
All right.
Well No,
if there's nothing else to specific,
you said addicted to newness.
So I feel this is the right time to play a little clip from you as a rapper.
Milne as Jesse James.
Lovely
was lucky.
I wanted to get my free book.
Nobody does wait.
I'll wait for fantastic.
But he moved like,
where am I getting slow?
Me Down
was one.
Let me get a pen.
In my case she said I was only in my money.
How was the pain foot at the five?
A couple bucks.
Same.
But y'all keep quiet.
Don't even try it.
I pulled through.
I love it.
But Nah,
she didn't fight it.
The store man back received diplomas of car.
She was laid off.
Wow.
Oh Man.
Jesse James that wasn't in the,
uh,
in the email that you sent me about the shelf that you're going to flash back.
We have a pretty crack research team around here.
We're going full flashback or before we get to the future and the present.
How did that happen?
Like I said,
grew up in long island in the 80s,
you know,
and hip hop was comment was emerging.
Um,
I got really into it at an early age and then when I was in college,
you know,
I,
when everybody was writing their resumes and sending out resumes,
I was like,
I'm gonna try and make a record.
You're like,
this is what I wanna do.
And,
um,
there was no B plan.
And ultimately,
you know,
that passion,
uh,
really,
for three years of college I was working towards trying to get a record deal and
ultimately landed a deal with a company called delicious vinyl out in Cali,
not far from where we are.
And they had two big accidents time.
They had a guy named Tony Local Roy.
Yeah.
Wild thing of called Medina.
And then they had had a little bit of a tone loke feel to it that yeah,
same producers.
Yeah.
And then we had a young Mc who won a grammy for buster move.
So I was able to,
uh,
I,
I didn't know that,
but literally I was watching it this morning and I said to David,
my producer that it's,
that's what it sounded like.
Yeah.
It's the same guys,
same year.
Same time.
Yeah.
And a,
and put an album out in the early nineties.
Wow.
So I was watching it and I was thinking,
man,
time changes,
you know,
things change.
We get sensitive to different things,
but I would guarantee it.
But if a young guy,
like you put that song out now talking about a white woman and a white rapper,
we'd have a certain amount of people screaming about cultural appropriation and
all sorts of other stuff.
Was that even remotely something back then?
Well,
you know,
I think it was a,
it was on my mind,
but the shaker,
like a white girl was my first single was actually a remake.
The title of an old EU song.
A of an old gogo song from washing abandoned Washington DC.
Huh.
Um,
that was predominant was all black.
So I felt like I was just kind of taking the momentum of this hit song.
Yeah.
And introducing it to the theme too.
You know,
it was fun.
I was in college,
I would,
I wrote the whole album basically,
you know,
as a fraternity in my fraternity house.
And um,
yeah,
it was pretty tongue in cheek.
Yeah.
It kind of makes you wish that things were as simple now as they were back then.
Right.
Cause you could,
could you,
are you following me on this?
Like I see like some fraternity kid doing something silly like that now and,
and just like getting just like a ton of shit for it.
Yeah.
I mean I'll eat it if it was totally good natured and all that.
It was totally good natured.
But I look back on it now and I think,
you know,
if I were to go back in time I probably would do a lot of things differently
just based on what I know now.
And you know,
I'm turning 50,
so I'm very aware of,
you know,
what chapter I am in my life.
But when I looked back at me at 21 and what I knew then and you know all the
mistakes,
I made a 21.
Uh,
but you know,
it's part of the growth and part of the journey.
Yeah.
All right.
So I want to get to some of the growth in the journey.
I want to get,
okay.
Cook and all that stuff.
Go,
wait,
let's just jump back to the,
to the go New York.
Go New York,
go.
How in the world did that even appear that you are going to be the guy that
wrote that thing and were you shocked that it caught on?
I mean,
the video which we'll uh,
we'll also link to down below.
I like,
I remember every moment of that.
So what happened for me is right after college,
no resume,
you know,
got rejected by a lot of record labels.
I had no context.
My Dad owned a plumbing supply house in Mineola,
also not from [inaudible].
I didn't know anyone that was connected to anything.
So I had to take this whole,
this whole process on my own shoulders and I would literally take a greyhound
bus on Friday from Washington DC where I went to school with my demo tape,
which was a recording of an instrumental that I played on my CD player.
And I would hit record on my answering machine and leave a wrap to the music
while it was playing.
That was out.
The only way I can man damn unbelievable.
Like that just sounds like a time warp.
I know.
That's,
that was the only way I could do it.
Then I would show up and hand out that cassette to everybody and got rejected.
But ultimately I did get a record.
I get,
I didn't get a record deal and um,
but that was my only goal.
So I took my foot off the gas pedal once I got the deal and I didn't get signed
for a second album,
which to me was crushing at the time.
Uh,
because the only thing on my resume now was,
you know,
failed rapper.
You know,
I was also a Kiddie pool attendant before there,
so that wasn't really going to get me a job on Wall Street.
That's like a low level life.
Low you're training,
like walk,
no peeing.
Like was if you could say walk and stop,
stop peeing.
You could get the job fair.
Always pinging,
you know that always to get them out of there.
But in any event,
um,
I wanted to stay even though I didn't get picked up for a second album,
I wanted to marry my two passions,
which was sports and music and I had this idea to write a theme song for the
next.
I was like,
all of a sudden sports,
we're changing.
The game is only 48 minutes and you're there,
you're a fan for for 48 minutes.
But for the other two hours that you're in the arena during timeouts,
you're an audience.
And the teams had to entertain the audience and now they brought in the dancers.
The Knicks city dancer is came in and they had video boards that all of a sudden
never existed.
So I was like,
let's do a theme song.
Like the bears did a song in 86.
Yeah,
let's do a theme song.
We'll get all the celebrities involved in and maybe it'll catch on.
So I wrote this demo basically in my apartment,
which was like a dorm room and I played it for the next and uh,
had you even get that meeting?
I had,
I started doing jingles,
uh,
and somehow I,
I did a jingle for Nancy Grunfeld clothing company or husband.
Ernie was the GM and she loved the jingle and I said,
well,
Nancy,
if you love this,
let's,
let's do something for the next.
Let's try this.
So she said,
we'll take a shot at.
So I just did it on Spec.
I walked in and I knew it.
There was something there and I played it for them and they said,
you know,
we'll,
we'll give you a $4,000 for the song.
And I said,
okay.
I hired a right then and there you said,
Right then and there.
Oh yeah.
No lawyer or nothing.
Dot.
I didn't ask any questions at $4,000 who's eight months of rent.
So I um,
when I hired a lawyer,
ultimately I needed a lawyer,
studio engineer,
Singer,
drummer,
producer,
et cetera.
It costs me $4,800 to do this song.
But every team that came into Madison Square Garden said,
why don't we have a theme so this and the next got hot and it became the number
one most requested song,
that little jingle on New York radio.
And I realized like that's the white space.
Nobody else is know.
Everyone's trying to get on MTV and get their records and tower records.
But no,
there's a category,
a new category that I can create sports,
music and I started doing theme songs for professional sports teams.
Yeah.
It's so awesome.
Like it's just such a great story of just like a kid,
basically a kid just like it over look,
just get out there and do something.
It's kind of a kind of a beautiful thing.
You must look at it back.
I can see sort of in your face,
like there's like a nostalgia to it cause it was just like I was what it was.
I look at it from that chapter of my life where I had 21 years old.
I,
there were no consequences.
Like if I didn't get this song,
I would have gotten to the next team and kept,
I was so deeply connected to my dream,
like emotionally connected to the goal that I would,
I was on greyhound bus every day drive.
I mean I would do anything.
So just to have the opportunity that it was just everything else was gravy.
Yeah.
So is that really where the entrepreneurial spirit started with you?
Because it seems like you've got that going and then that opened up a whole slew
of other doors that opened up the flood gates for some big,
for some big futures,
you know,
successes and failures.
But,
and I was thinking about this actually yesterday on a run,
you know,
I used to,
you'll probably remember,
I don't know if you're into tennis,
but the US Open was right by,
you know,
you take oh yeah,
flushing.
Yes,
we would just take the train,
you know,
there were no rules.
My,
my parents,
there's almost a home.
By eight o'clock at night I would take the train and I remember I would never
have a ticket and all I could look,
I would look forward to being able to try to sneak into the u s open.
And I remember though that I've kind of figured out how to sneak into the u s
open regularly.
So I would go,
no ticket,
everyone's online.
And I would go to like how I went in and then I would walk out and see if I
could do it again somewhere else.
And that was really the start of like,
as I look back,
like I just want,
I like challenges.
Yeah.
It doesn't,
does not about anything other than can I figure it out?
And,
and it started for me at an early age and ultimately it gravitate,
you know,
it started to gravitate towards business.
Yeah.
So let's,
let's get there.
So,
okay,
you're making the jingles.
Some things happen.
You're obviously making money,
probably some serious money for the first time.
How does this get you to starting incubators and starting these couples?
Every team that came into Madison Square Garden say,
why don't we have a song like this who did this?
And I was the guy.
So I started writing all these teams songs and ultimately sold that company to a
public company called SFX.
And the owner of SFX had a timeshare in a private jet and he invited was like 26
years old.
And he invited my partner and I as guests onto his private jet.
And it was like the scene in the wizard of Oz when we walked on the plane,
when everything goes from black and white color,
I walked on the plane,
I'm like,
people fly like this.
And by the time we landed,
my partner turned to me,
he's like,
we've got to start a private jet companies so we can fly around on these planes.
And I was like,
let's do it.
That's hilarious.
And that's literally how we started this company that ultimately be called,
I was called Marquis jet that um,
became the largest private jet car company in the world.
So you were eventually sold the company,
it's called [inaudible].
It was called Marquis jet.
You sold it to a Warren Buffet's yeah,
net jets,
which is a Berkshire Hathaway company.
And then so then now you're rolling in bill.
Um,
it was,
it was a change,
definitely a life changing moment for me.
Um,
but again,
I love newness and I was,
uh,
at that time in my life I had just ran a hundred mile run for charity and I gave
myself 90 days to train for it.
And during the process of,
of my training,
I discovered coconut water cause I did a lot of research around hydration and
nutrition.
If you're going to run 24,
100 miles nonstop,
what do you eat,
what you drink and how many calories you take in.
And um,
you're experimenting with that,
with that now through your new diet,
which are going through.
But I discovered coconut water and which ultimately,
you know,
I fueled me for this race that I completed and when I was done I was like,
man,
this is the fountain of Youth.
This is going to be the next big thing in beverage.
You know,
it's like this is the next orange juice is the next palm.
Wonderful.
And I spent a year traveling the globe trying to figure out how to import
coconut water where yours is.
This is a 2007,
2007 so like there money,
cause it's not that long ago and yet coconut orders so massive right now.
Right.
You'd think this would have to be 25 years ago.
But in 2007 it wasn't even on the show.
And there was one skew on the shelf.
Yeah,
it wasn't,
it didn't really exist.
Um,
but I realized that the learning curve,
I got like a nine 80 MSAT.
The learning curve was 1200.
Okay.
All right.
Were them old ones.
I should have called you.
I couldn't figure it out,
man.
I'm like,
I know I can market this,
but like I don't know how I'm going to import this as so many moving pieces.
So I ended up partnering with the company that was uh,
you know,
on the scene called Zico,
just doing a couple of million dollars in sales.
And then ultimately two years later we sold it the coke.
So then,
then you're really in the business world.
Like at that point you've two companies
and,
and your role and how do you then go,
all right,
I like newness.
What's new after this?
Um,
cause that's when your story seems to be,
it's just like another,
what's new,
what's new.
But I get bored easily and I just,
you know,
I believe in checking the box and like not celebrating what happened,
happen,
what's next.
And you know,
my whole thing,
I always talk about this,
it's just about building my own personal life resume,
not even my business resume.
And Like I love adventure.
So I was just looking for,
you know,
whatever that next opportunity was.
And it became,
it was not for me at,
in the timeline of my life.
The next thing was a book,
but it wasn't planned.
It wasn't planned.
Let's,
let's talk about that book a little bit before we get to this book.
Yeah.
I was at a,
uh,
at a race,
a 24 hour race.
I love endurance.
I participate in a lot of endurance events and um,
the race was,
was a really,
really format.
So I was with five friends and each runs a mile and you rotate and whatever team
runs the most amount of miles in 24 hours wins the competition.
But at the start of the race,
there was a guy sitting next to us,
had no one to really with,
he had no teammates.
He was his own team and he weighed like 285 pounds,
just big African American guy just sitting in a chair.
And I'm thinking myself,
how in the world is a guy that weighs two 85 going to run for 24 straight hours?
And the race was on,
are you even allowed?
They let you run a relay.
One guy.
You were just like the only solo you know,
by himself.
And it was just like,
and I was just so big and intimidating and the race was unsupported.
So they,
they provide nothing.
It was on a dirt one mile,
unlit parking lot.
And you had to even bring their own water.
I mean they gave you nothing.
So I had just sold my company.
I like,
I went crazy on our side.
I as a Seuss's,
a table fell off like 10.
This guy had three items,
a box of crackers,
a fold up chair and a bottle of water.
And I was like,
man,
have this isn't gonna work out well.
And sure enough that mouth 70 he,
because of his weight,
he had broken multiple bones in both of his feet.
He crushed the bones in his feet.
He's from just the pounding,
cause he was just so big and because he only had water and crackers,
he had kidney failure and he was peeing blood down his leg.
And my first reaction is,
man,
but we've got to get this guy a medic immediately like air lift him out of here
to a hospital.
But what did he do?
He gets out of the chair,
picks himself up,
runs another 30 miles to get to his goal of a hundred and then runs one more in
case they miscounted.
And I immediately was like,
man,
I gotta,
I gotta meet this guy,
I got to meet him because whatever secrets sauce he has,
like whatever drive he has to get them out,
get them out of the chair.
You don't even get a ribbon for affinity.
Like they'd like pat you on the back.
Good job.
There's no trophy.
You don't get extra crackers.
No,
this is like you go home and that's that.
Whatever got him out of the chair.
If I could teach that to my kids,
if I could apply that drive to the multiple buckets of my life,
then all the areas of my life would be so much better.
So I ended up calling,
you know,
googling,
I'm fanning out,
he was a navy seal.
I cold called them and we sat down for lunch and I realized I would never get
the secret sauce in a lunch meeting and just ask them like,
would you come live with me for a month?
And he said to me,
um,
basically direct quote,
if you're crazy enough to ask a guy like me to come live with you mother Fucker,
I'm crazy enough to come.
And that was the start of our journey.
So you've spent how much time?
I spend a month.
He came and moved into with my wife,
Sarah,
myself.
And at the time my son had one child,
we should mention his name because let's give them the credit.
David Goggins,
he's an amazing human and American and I'm with an amazing story.
Came and live with my wife and I and my son for a,
for 30 days.
What did your wife think about this?
Oh,
I'm bringing a navy seal and for a month she called me after the lunch meeting
and she said,
you know,
how did it go?
And I said,
very quickly isn't on live with us.
You know what I know,
like got into a big fuss.
I said,
no,
he's actually sweeties coming to live with us on Friday.
And um,
no,
I mean she wants,
he came in,
they immediately took to each other and um,
it was just an amazing journey and I never thought the notion of writing a book
never crossed my mind.
In fact,
the book came out,
the book living with a seal came out five years after he actually lived with us.
Um,
because as I started to put some of the tools that I,
I learned and what I learned about myself and about his mindset into action and
share with others,
I was like,
Whoa,
there's a,
there's something here.
And that sort of how it came to fruition.
Yeah.
Let's explore some of that stuff.
So he gets to your house first day,
like,
did you have a plan or were you just like,
take over man,
you got a month?
Like,
make me better.
I said to him,
make yourself at home is the first thing I said to him.
And I said,
you know,
our home is your home and you walked right over to me and he said,
I,
I don't have a home.
As I know,
make yourself at home is just an expression.
And again,
he got a little closer,
like nose to nose.
And he said,
I don't operate in expressions as like,
oh,
gay,
great little grape,
30 day house guests.
And he said,
in fact,
get your stuff on.
Let's go see where you're at.
Physically would go down to the gym so I can map out the month.
And when he came and lived with us at that time in my life,
I was in a great spot.
You know,
I was married,
I'm still married,
um,
had had a child and now for had some failure,
had some success,
but I was in,
I thought I was in a really good spot,
but like so many of us,
I was in a routine and I was really comfortable in my routine.
My routine was get up,
workout hard,
go to work all day,
come home,
have dinner with my wife and child,
little bit alone time repeat.
And like,
I thought I was operating up here,
but I was so comfortable I couldn't get out of it.
And like you routines are great,
but they can also be a Rut.
Like I realized like I don't wanna fucking go through life like this.
Like I'm gonna go through life like this.
I got to get out of my routine man,
otherwise I'm going to wake up and it'd be 70 so you think that that routine,
even when it's all going well and it sounds like things were going pretty well
for you,
that no matter what,
that that level of routine will automatically stifle creativity without question
and,
and time goes fast.
Like I have four kids,
I want to slow the clock down.
Yeah.
And if I'm in a routine and you're in routine,
you miss a lot of opportunities,
at least for me,
that's the way I found my life to unfold.
And I feel like when I step out of routine,
you know,
when I go into the unknown,
that's where amazing growth happens.
And that's where I feel most alive.
And that's where I get the most benefit.
And that's why as a check the box and move on mentality.
And that's what this opportunity was for me.
Nothing other than to,
you know,
to step into the unknown.
He represented unknown and a,
and a little bit of secret sauce.
So we'd go down on my gym and you know,
he's like,
let me see how many posts you can do.
So I got up and I,
you know,
I can run pretty far in a circle or a straight line for a long time,
but not really strong.
So I did like a like eight pull ups,
which is an exaggeration for like four pole to pole to full up.
And then he started wait 30 seconds and do it again.
So I got back on the bar and I did again,
like one or two or something,
you know,
barely said,
wait 30 seconds,
I want you to do it again.
And now,
like my arms are,
you know,
I can get back on the barn.
I'm trying to get my chin up over the bar.
And I dropped down and I started,
well,
what's next?
And he said,
well,
what's next is we're not leaving here until you do a hundred more Jesus Christ.
And I said,
like,
that's impossible.
I can't do a hundred and he said to me,
well,
I already know what your biggest problem is,
but probably what all of our biggest problem is.
And he said,
I'm the limitations that you're putting on herself that we put on ourselves are
self imposed and I'm going to prove it to you.
So get back up on fucking bar and give me a pull up.
So I did a pull up and I dropped down and I repeated that process until I did
all a hundred holy.
And I realize it took,
it took like two hours.
But I realized that that moment that if I'm under indexing by a hundred pull
ups,
like what are the areas of my life and my under indexing it,
you know,
am I under indexing at work with my wife and my relationships?
Am I comfortable?
Am I in this routine?
I mean,
I just didn't want to go to that place of pain to see what I was really made of.
And that started our journey and that was a constant theme of like how far can
you take this Jesse?
Like,
you know,
why are you holding yourself back?
And not just physically but in,
in everything and work.
Okay,
you've had some success,
but how do you know your limits?
It's like when I started running,
my goal was drawn two miles.
If I could run two miles in 18 minutes,
I consider myself a runner and that was it.
And I worked hard to get,
took me weeks to go from the couch to those two miles.
There's a lot of people with a gun to their head.
They can run two miles right now.
Nothing changed in my body since then.
Same leg,
same lungs.
God gave me saying I'm not really strong,
but I was able to take that same body guy gave me from two miles and ultimately
take it to a hundred miles without stopping.
And the only thing that changed was what I thought I could do.
So if I was under indexing 50 x in that area again,
what am I limits and business?
What am I limits in my life?
Resume and how I live my life and what am I limits and how deep my relationships
can be and what am I limits in how much I can learn and we're travel or
anything.
Yeah.
So I think it's probably easy for people at some level to understand the
quantifiable stuff.
I can run faster,
I can lift more,
that kind of stuff.
Could you talk about it sort of on the mental side,
on the relationship side?
Like how do you actually judge what are the right ways to spread yourself in
those areas?
Sure.
Well,
I mean I think that,
I think for me,
I think a lot of people,
and we think about relationships,
we think of relationships between people.
How was your relationship with your parents or your child or your husband or
wife or whatever it is.
And I think one thing that's often very neglected is our relationship with time
and talked about quantifiable stuff.
And I'm very aware of my relationship with time.
That's been a fundamental shift for me over the last couple of years.
And maybe cause I've turned 50 but I was recently on a,
on a camping trip.
You look like you're 28 he's doing something right.
I don't know man,
it's the long island jeans.
But I was recently on a camping trip and I was with a friend of mine as a police
officer and stuff that county,
county.
He had his daughter,
I had my son and we went on and on a cold winter,
Mount Washington lizardy outdoor,
sleeping in the snow camping trip.
And I turned to him,
I said,
Kevin,
how often did you trip do trips like this?
And this is a guy that's a police officer,
you know,
one of the happiest guys I know,
probably not super well off.
I mean,
you know,
blue collar guy,
extremely happy.
And he says,
I take,
he said every year I take one trip a year with my college friends.
I've been doing it to some 21 years old.
Then every other month I take a trip with my family or myself.
It could be running a marathon,
it could be go to the lake,
it could be go on a hike,
whatever.
And I said to myself,
if I can't take,
I call it Kevin's rule,
one weekend every eight weeks for my own adventure with my family,
with friends.
And it doesn't have to be something that costs a lot of money.
But if I can think five or six of those a year,
then I'm way out of balance.
So it might not be a direct answer to your question,
but what I'm saying is,
you know,
you,
you could in the past,
maybe that would be one or two times a year and I wouldn't even be aware of it.
But once you become aware of it,
look over the next 30 years,
you're talking about 150 memories.
You know,
it's all cumulative as opposed to maybe 2030 memories.
That's the difference of like a really full life.
It could be at the end of the day with no regrets,
with no regrets versus someone that's in their routine going through life like
this.
And then you wake up and you're 75 and you're like,
fuck,
I don't have the energy to go to Mt.
Washington anymore.
I don't have my son.
My kids are grown up.
So those kinds of shifts are measurable and I can pinpoint an end time,
I can pinpoint into my relationship with my wife and just Friday night dinners,
Wednesday night,
date night.
It's just what's your relationship with time?
How do you spend it,
who do you spend it with and are you doing the things you love to do?
Yeah.
Well that's definitely a good segue to living with monks so quickly though.
Do you have some of those people in your life where Kevin just said about
reconnect with the high school friends and that,
cause I find now a couple of my most valuable relationships that I have right
now are with one of them's Mike Trout who'd best friends since um,
since we were four years old,
I remember meeting the guy and in kindergarten we are,
I think maybe it was the day before kindergarten and then another friend from
third grade.
And we've stayed connected.
And because of that,
it helps me frame the future because we've been having these same conversations
about love and life and sports and politics forever.
And it's like watching us all,
you know,
one of them lives in jersey,
ones in Texas,
and I'm here in La.
And yet our journeys,
they still matter to each other.
So I think it helps like set the future sort of.
Yeah,
I'm fortunate that I do.
Uh,
I'm so,
you know,
so still have the same high school friends and friends from my neighborhood when
I grew up,
still super close too.
And I think you're right.
You know,
we're so lucky to have that and uh,
it's,
you know,
it's still a big part of my life that those relationships and also,
they can relate to the backstory very often.
If I meet someone now they know Jessie had 50,
they don't know Jesse at six and Roz and little league and they don't know
Jesse,
you know,
we,
we probably are,
you're a couple of years older than you guys can say.
We probably played little league against each other,
but you've got a couple of years out.
Right,
right,
right.
But same,
same thing.
Handling.
Yeah.
Um,
so I agree with you.
I agree with you and,
but,
you know,
I,
I think all of my friends from high school and even college,
and even today,
I mean,
they invest time and keeping those relationships.
So,
and you can do it easily now through Facebook and social media and this kind of
stuff,
but often we don't.
But I'm,
I'm fortunate that my group of friends,
we do,
you know,
we had for awhile,
we had a newsletter that we put together for each other.
And,
um,
it makes me smile just thinking about it now,
you know what I mean?
Uh,
just feel really lucky.